this week marks the 100th anniversary of
the ratification of the 19th amendment
which gave women the right to vote but
most black women could not actually vote
until decades later
in the words of my favorite philosopher
chris rock from head of state that ain't
right
on this historic centennial we are
celebrating the milestone and exploring
the long struggle
for full equality adriana diaz reports
from chicago where she spoke with
generations of women about the past
the present and the future in the fight
for women's rights
in illinois women had the right to vote
in national and municipal elections
before the 19th amendment
making this the first state east of the
mississippi river to grant
partial suffrage to women but in 1915
here at the art institute of chicago
women advocated for national voting
rights
they had a banner that said we demand an
amendment to the u.s constitution
enfranchising women but not all women
were included
can you read what that sentence says jim
crow laws and other barriers made it
nearly impossible for black women to
exercise their legal right to vote
native american and asian women often
faced citizenship questions when they
went to the ballot box
it was kind of a victory for white women
and still a struggle for women of color
michelle duster is the great
granddaughter of ida b
wells an investigative journalist an
anti-lynching crusader
and a fierce suffragist it's amazing to
think that she
walked up these various steps we met
outside the historic chicago home where
wells lived with her family
what is the pride that you feel being
the great granddaughter of iwells
i'm honored to be related to somebody
who's contributed so much to
our country born into slavery in 1862
mississippi
wells spent her life championing justice
and equality
in 1884 at just 21 years old
she was on a train and refused to move
to the colored car
then she sued the railroad it's almost
as if she was
rosa parks before rosa parks rosa parks
wasn't even born
she was ida b wells before rosa parks
was ida b wells jr
women had deeper freedoms in mind for
women of color
the struggle for full voting rights
continued for decades after wells death
[Music]
until finally at the height of the civil
rights movement
the voting rights act was signed into
law in 1965
but still barriers remain today are you
registering for the first time
yes the league of women voters is on the
front lines of that fight
combating voter suppression and opposing
discriminatory voter id
laws reach out to everyone you know
among its ranks are league members lolly
watt and her 23 year old daughter leah
i think it's more critical than ever and
that
has really focused us on making sure
that every voter
gets to vote how they want
safely and in an informed way
the right to vote is something that watt
an immigrant from india
does not take for granted as a
naturalized american
i made a decision to be american right i
felt i was joining a country which was
working to be as good as it could be and
that's what keeps me going
it's like i can actually have an impact
in this country
as you look toward the presidential
election what are the concerns that you
have
as you try to get out the vote voter
suppression is a huge concern because
there's an easy way with the pandemic in
kovid to say
we're shutting down all these polling
stations for safety
but then you look at the ones that are
being shut down and it's kind of clear
voter suppression
at work the continued fight to defend
every citizen's right to have an impact
through voting
is the lasting legacy of american
suffragists the monument will be here
yes like ida b wells her great
granddaughter hopes to create a
permanent symbol of inspiration
for future generations for many many
years only men can vote
like these young cousins who we found
near those same chicago steps where
suffrage leaders stood
more than a century ago i think it's
incredible that
all the women can come together to get
what they want and what they believe
they deserve in this country and i'm so
proud of that
so is everybody here going to vote
eventually
when you're 18 definitely yes
those girls give us hope for our future
and honoring our past
last year this street was renamed ida b
wells drive it's the first major street
in chicago to be named for an
african-american woman
her great-granddaughter michelle duster
was of course part of that effort she's
also written several books about wells
the latest will be released next year by
simon
schuster a division of viacom cbs and i
just love the title
i to be the queen anthony
oh gosh adriana i just love your story
and i love michelle duster the great
granddaughter which she said oh let's
let's put this in perspective rosa parks
was ida b wells jr
not the other way around and it's so
interesting how much we take for granted
that's why this story is so important to
let
young girls know what people went
through so we could all have the right
to vote
absolutely you know we all have to
exercise that right that so many people
fought for for all of us
yes all right 74 days we all get the
chance to go to the polls
thank you adriana diaz good to see you